category jerry what is it all right next
category is oh this one's a new one as
well for this year this is my favorite
one the most privileged moment oh
so you know i think
the biggest difference from like last
year and this year is that uh we have
found out how big a podcast could become
we didn't really
know that last year um so you know you
might have seen uh yeah what was that
conversation without where uh it was
like you've changed yeah right i changed
right yeah this this is that award yeah
that you've changed but you've changed
the world your nominations though uh we
got sysnap doesn't want to be cool
i think i'm just like yeah because at
this point conor keeps calling me poor
and it's like honestly at any time i
could get something where i'm like
i'm not boring
[Music]
that's such a long in-joke explanation
sydney would hate it when i i used to
call her paul so i used to always call
her poor to piss her off
that's like that's like proceeds
very very long running thing where was i
you were in the toilet i guess oh i was
pooping oh okay okay okay
okay okay okay that makes a lot of sense
i was like what the [ __ ] did this happen
i do not remember this
this one this one this one yeah they go
yeah i'm i'm really sorry and i'm like
okay maybe we do need to get two rooms
and we're like yeah i'm really sorry all
the king-sized beds are gone this one
only has a queen-size bed
and i'm like
this is a hotel i would stay in if i was
on holiday right we walk in
and there's a hallway that leads to our
bed right
and then so we walk in with me and
sydney look at each other and and i'm
just like
the gacha gods are on my side
i think what makes this even better is
just knowing that honestly
like a peasant hotel like i love it i
love it that's so good yeah yeah and
then connor spent a thousand dollars on
the goku drip jacket i'm going to do it
again i'd do it again very privileged
extremely pretty so just to win the best
trip and he didn't win that i didn't win
to win best okay okay okay because it's
iconic no you absolutely won it for the
best i don't know i wanted it because i
wanted it
it's an iconic meme history piece oh you
got a steel card you got a steal there's
only a thousand bucks a thousand only a
thousand bucks
only
and then there's the boys going to
playing golf
is this privilege
is this privileged calling out every
golf player now what the [ __ ]
because i recently got back into golf um
and i was like my god that is the most
boomer thing i've ever done see i don't
i don't think golf is a boomer thing you
know i i feel like it's a pretty much i
don't think it's a difference yeah it's
a privileged movie thing you know if
you're broke you can't be playing golf
that's just facts
that's true okay okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah we uh we utter the word privilege
yeah yeah i guess that makes sense and
then there's connor complains about his
free quarantine dude these means were
[ __ ] these are abhorrent i don't even
have good taste because this one wasn't
even controversy that was like started
on the podcast yeah it was controversy
that was started on twitter by kind of
posting his like image you had to be
done right and then the meals were crap
right yeah so you guys sent me pictures
of them oh yeah i got i i posted one of
them and i was like this is the saddest
breakfast ever and it caused like a
[ __ ] argument
you almost got cancelled on twitter for
that didn't everyone's like people like
man connor's privilege just been acting
out so much
people acting like i [ __ ] went to
like eaten school and went to cambridge
because i said one meal was [ __ ] he
wanted to get the [ __ ] over themselves
i hope that one would i could just say
cause like
like just looking at that image i was
just like that's a very aesthetic image
that's good
if i'm going to the [ __ ] kids store
to get a playmobil set of fake food it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it's all cold and hard
it's so bad it's just the way that like
even with like the worst meals they can
serve they still serve like really good
aesthetic looking meals
i want that to win just like the
dichotomy of just kind of go like this
[ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't like the
picture you're looking pretty damn good
well let's find out there all right
let's find out the most privileged
moment of the trash days awards is
connor spent a thousand dollars on the
goku drip jacket i'll take that that's
the privilege i want that's the kind of
privilege i need around here
it was a bit more than a thousand
actually it was like a thousand yeah or
something
important i mean it's all it's all
privileged uh who
who topped the charts for that top three
what's top three ooh all top three were
all pretty close um connor won that one
with 26.1 percent of the vote
uh sit snap came in second with
seven percent of the vote on sydney hold
on
and nearly privileged yeah and in third
place was god's quarantine hotel with
twenty two point one possible workout
privilege gone damn well i guess you can
still call sydney poor then because
she's less privileged than uconn
[Laughter]
so we talk a lot of [ __ ]
on your trash talk this is the what i've
been waiting for we talk we talk a lot
of [ __ ] uh and we might not always
fact-check what we say
uh so this is the i made it the [ __ ] up
award
where
where i'm i'm glad that uh we're not
part of the scientific community where
we have to cite our sources yeah uh
because ninety percent of the time we
never have so i'm glad people don't take
this show seriously yeah because my god
yeah so what are the nominations for
this one
all right starting off strong oh my god
all of these uh 2021 anime wasn't good
that was definitely like i made it the
[ __ ] out i'll admit to this one i
definitely made this the [ __ ] up that
came back to bite you so i came back
everyone used that to discredit you yeah
pretty much pretty much because i
remember because like i don't remember
when you said this but i was i because i
was like i watched 2021 anime i [ __ ]
loved 2021 anime so like when this got
spread around i was like did joey say
that i definitely would have given him
[ __ ] if he said that i was surprised i
think i remember still i was surprised
with the lack of [ __ ] i got on the
episode
you guys were kind of just like is that
right
that was it i don't watch any of it
right yeah uh and then we have uh from
after dark where fish don't exist that's
still true you can google it i just
explained it poorly yeah yeah that was
just like a poor explanation yeah
this one wasn't a poor explanation
i still stand by this to the stage
i feel poisoning as an illness in my
mind it's your poison it's just
when like jen said the most wild [ __ ] in
this episode yeah somehow they still got
more offended than joseph yeah
jen literally said like so many
misogynist comments and then this was
the one
jan was just like so yeah here's the
entire dark world of the [ __ ] host
club world a lot of shady things going
on and they're like algebra on cape
aren't capable being social what the
[ __ ] pause the episode that's right draw
the line i'm dumb because the thing the
thing that stands out about this is that
out of all of these right i think this
was the only one where i like i like
corrected you for that one
yeah because i think i actually did
correct you yeah you're trying to
correct me to the best of your ability
but yeah yeah but you just have one
having it i remember i folded pretty
quickly on the introverts yeah cause i
realized what i said yeah but the 2021
one everyone was just like is that right
you know what it just says a lot about
me that as much as food poisoning isn't
an illness it's like an outrageous and
just i like you talk to your doctor it's
just factually wrong you know like
you've turned you've turned the
factually the wrong thing into like just
like a feeling now yeah yeah yeah yeah
i still got a couple of twenty i still
think it's 20 21 anime i'm surprised
there's some other funny moments i
remember when i said that like pokemon
was the most googled thing in 1996 and
google didn't exist
i'm surprised
i think it's because we didn't like
you know when we were all like oh really
yeah i think that one wasn't brought up
because it was just you it was just an
out of context line yeah because it was
just like i remember hearing that and i
remember thinking that doesn't sound
right but my knowledge isn't good enough
to try and argue that fact am i crazy it
was the most google thing in one of the
years i can't remember which year it was
it wasn't 19.
it was a shame she was like you had the
right meaning just [ __ ] up the
execution yeah exactly exactly because i
feel like a lot more lines that were
just passed over weren't nominated
i remember there has been plenty of
plenty of moments where we've stopped
recording and then we've realized what
we said the day after and we were just
like why did no one challenge me on this
and we were like well we we didn't know
either because all of us are just like i
guess you're right he said it with such
confidence yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right all right what's the uh what's the
winner of this one you know what i i
hope i win this one with the i made it
the [ __ ] up award goes to
2021 anime wasn't any good
you know what i can't even defend myself
on that because i didn't watch anything
in 2021 bro joey literally made it i
made it [ __ ] up that was the most i made
it that was good i definitely made it
the [ __ ] yeah well all the percentages
though
wasn't even close forty six point nine
percent forty seven forty six point nine
percent six point
uh connor's food poisoning came in at i
thought that was going to be strong
connection second with 29 points with 29
oh my god
oh sorry not sorry i guess